ladies and gentlemen
i present
the super
nintendo
[Music]
this super nintendo is my favorite
system of all time it first released to
japan in november of 1990 as the super
famicom and it was an immediate success
300 000 units flew off of the shelves in
hours people were missing work to pick
up the system sheen constant times were
missed by seconds and the japanese
government had had enough of this utter
mayhem the immediate popularity of the
super famicom caused the government to
declare no more console releases on
weekdays
and yet only two games launched with the
system super mario world and f-zero
which might not seem like much except
that super mario world is one of the
greatest platform games of all time
super mario world perfectly encapsulated
what a mario platform game was and
showcased the new power of the super
famicom it was filled with far more
color than the limited palette of the
famicom and its music could use a far
wider range of sound from a design
perspective the game featured an
incredibly satisfying approach to
difficulty it included secret buttons
that could be found to produce various
color blocks the player could use
finding these buttons didn't only feel
rewarding but also filled each stage
with new platforms effectively making
the game easier for players who weren't
as skilled it meant that exploration and
secrets yielded real rewards giving
players an incentive to explore each of
the game's many interesting and fun
levels not only this but super mario
world introduced the world to yoshi
miyamoto had initially envisioned mario
as being able to ride a dinosaur or at
the very least horseback riding and with
the new power of the super famicom this
dream was realized and yoshi was created
on top of being incredibly cute yoshi
also further helped create a balance in
difficulty as the character also served
as another hit mario could take without
dying
[Music]
then there was f-zero
the super nintendo featured eight
distinct video modes programmers could
choose in order to maximize the look and
feel of their games these modes included
layering effects with some specializing
in multiple layers allowing for more
dynamic parallax scrolling meanwhile the
most famous of these modes was mode 7.
mode 7 allowed developers to rotate and
scroll assets which in turn allowed them
to create various illusions that they
could utilize for gameplay or visual
flair super mario world utilized this
for some of its bosses pulling and
stretching however other games like
super castlevania 4 use this trick to
make entire levels rotate as an extra
obstacle or for visual effects within
the backgrounds many games utilize mode
7 to create a sense of depth for enemies
flying from background to foreground or
vice versa
f0 utilized this mode to showcase racing
in a whole new way while racing was by
no means a new genre mode 7 truly upped
the ante for showing speed and intensity
within a racing game on consoles by
using mode 7 to rotate the game's race
track and city underneath f-zero was
able to create a unique sense of speed
and soon after that a third game was
released bamboozle
you remember
okay the game might have been a fine
puzzle game it's just not very well
known so with these fantastic launch
titles and even more on their way for
the north american release when the
super nintendo made its way to the
united states in 1991
it was received
poorly
okay i mean by some people he has a game
boy and now he has the nintendo and now
he'd have to have another unit just for
that one game
doesn't seem right i'm going to say no
and i'm going to explain to him how
people market things to make you spend
more money some parents at the time
weren't happy that they had to spend
more money on a new system to play the
latest games newspaper articles and tv
reports showcased this resentment from a
certain portion of parents who didn't
grasp the difference between the systems
you see back then in the early days of
consoles not everyone fully grasped that
occasionally you would need to update
hardware to play better games the
console cycle wasn't really established
in the united states yet you had the
atari 5200 which was a major upgrade to
the popular atari 2600
but it released around the time of the
major video game crash of the 80s and
didn't sell well
at all
you'd still think that even the most
aloof parents could tell the difference
between an atari 2600 game and an nes
game but lucky kids got a super nintendo
nintendo
beyond just games the super nintendo had
another major upgrade on the nes
this baby the super nintendo also
upgraded its controller while the nes
controller was perfect for its time with
a simplistic uncomplicated design that
featured only two main buttons and a
brand new d-pad instead of a joystick
the super nintendo took this design and
added a level of complexity while still
keeping the controller simple and
ergonomic now there were four buttons
and in the layout still used for modern
controllers today
additionally there were now l and r
shoulder buttons of all of the additions
i think this was the most useful and
interesting shoulder buttons are now
standard and absolutely vital to many
games but they weren't a thing before
the snes while the sega genesis which
was released before the super nintendo
featured three buttons instead of two
even that controller didn't have the
shoulder buttons all of this meant that
games could be more complex and the
controller didn't sacrifice on
simplicity too many buttons can
definitely be the downfall for someone
new and this was the perfect compromise
before i gush about some of my favorite
games we also need to
discuss this guy
sonic 1989 and especially 1991 marked a
pivotal point for nintendo in the form
of a brand new competitor
while sega had released its master
system to north america in order to
compete with nes in 1986 it didn't
perform all that well
however it released its far more
upgraded mega drive or sega genesis to
na in 1989
it slowly gained traction but especially
exploded thanks to their brand new
mascot in 1991
bubs
sonic
bugsy with this brand new mascot and
competition sega brought the heat
hey
i mean i don't take offense to that but
rude enter
the great console wars of the 90s
two consoles entered and people were
quick to form allegiances we lost many
brave young children to playground spats
sonic was known for his speed and
attitude chili dog
[ __ ] sega marketed this as well as the
company's growing sports collection to
make the sega genesis seem like the
system for cool kids who sipped on capri
sun and wore their hats so far backwards
that they were forwards again
meanwhile nintendo kept their
family-friendly attitude basically
becoming the disney of video games they
focused on quality first their games
would speak for themselves the sega
genesis has blast processing super
nintendo doesn't
and what if you don't have blast
processing
damn it sega why do you have to make fun
of me so much
i loved mario kart
another loss
[Music]
the thing is whether nintendo liked it
or not they didn't this competition
brought out the best in both companies
it meant that nintendo couldn't get
complacent it had to innovate and it had
to continue to up its game otherwise it
would lose out to sega and as a consumer
that meant that everyone won regardless
of which console they had thanks to a
constant stream of fantastic games games
like what you ask well i'm glad you
asked there was
the nintendo holy trinity
i don't own super metroid yet beyond
super mario world super metroid and
zelda a link to the past both built upon
their foundations with some of the most
memorable games in their franchises a
link to the past built on zelda's theme
of exploration with an alternate
dimension of hyrule in the dark world
with this players could jump back and
forth between dimensions allowing for an
even deeper level of exploration puzzles
and secrets while the original metroid
on the nes established the
side-scrolling metroidvania super
metroid took that and created a far more
memorable experience improving in every
conceivable aspect thanks to the up
graphics of the super nintendo every
area now felt unique and samus's new
upgrades and abilities allowed for
interesting new ways to explore with
paths that truly made you feel clever
for figuring them out and then there was
the rise of jrpgs
games like chrono trigger secret of mana
mario rpg final fantasy earthbound and
well so many more fantastic games
established the super nintendo as the
machine to have if you were a fan of
this genre and while jrpgs began on the
nes and truly came to market prominence
with the playstation it was thanks to
the power of the super nintendo that
they could expand to the large scope of
adventure they'd always reached for
these games now looked absolutely
stunning and the soundtracks from these
games are still fondly regarded as some
of gaming's best with memorable tracks
by passionate composers of course this
was also the heyday of character driven
platformers and action games and while
admittedly the overabundance of this
style could be likened to fps games in
the late 2000s or early 2010s that also
meant that some of gaming's best came
out around this time
also i personally love this style of
game so i don't really mind mega man saw
a return to the super nintendo in the
mega man x series where the best of the
original titles focused on limited
mechanics with simple and fun gameplay
the x titles brought in an abundance of
secrets and upgrades making exploration
an important factor there were also
other great single-player experiences
like aladdin or sparkster sequel to
rocket knight adventure and for my money
one of the most underrated characters i
mean come on it was a possum in a night
outfit with a jet pack
another factor that really added to the
super nintendo was that many of these
games now included cooperative elements
no longer did you have to play a
platform game alone or take turns with
it many games now look for creative
solutions and look yes mario 3 had co-op
with players taking turns but i'm
talking about this kirby's superstar
saga let a second player play on screen
as buddies created from enemies of the
game like kirby whose power always
fluctuated this allowed for a second
player to also consistently shift
abilities and the game's laid-back
gameplay was perfect for two players at
once
meanwhile donkey kong country had its
own unique approach to multiplayer in
co-op each player controlled a different
character and while only one player
could play at a time any time someone
was hit that meant to switch to the
other player it was a fantastic way to
incentivize playing well while ensuring
each player had a fair turn to play the
point is the super nintendo quickly
became a system that allowed friends to
play together more so than the nes ever
had donkey kong country also looked
amazing for its time
with these games rare used a special
technique to compress 3d models into
snes sprites effectively cheating a 3d
look that absolutely blew consumers away
but it does highlight that game
developers were always looking for and
finding ways to increase the
capabilities of the super nintendo
similar to the nes the super nintendo
allowed game manufacturers to purchase
and utilize more advanced chips that
would go inside the cartridge itself
these allowed developers to do things
that were far beyond the initial
capabilities of the system examples
included the cx4 chip which allowed
capcom to create wireframe effects and
rotation as seen in mega man x2
those graphics dsp1 on the other hand
allowed for games to better utilize mode
7 for more advanced scaling and was seen
used in titles like super mario kart
which was also notable for kickstarting
the entire kart racing genre but the
most well known was the super fx chip
this is the chip that was utilized in
star fox and used to create a 3d polygon
effect on the super nintendo the game
was revolutionary and while the
technology was certainly impressive at
the time what was better was just how
fun the game was and how it took the
format of space harrier but was able to
still make something that felt wholly
new
also i feel like this game might have
contributed to my love for foxes shout
out to juniper fox and save a fox
then there were genres that grew and
were common to the era
like
fighting games and beat em ups
okay honestly i prefer playing fighting
is on my sega genesis
but they still existed on the super
nintendo street fighter 2 and mortal
kombat were by far the most influential
arcade fighters and the amazing thing
about this era was while the nes kind of
replicated that arcade feel this was the
first time we started to see consoles
mostly emulate a lot of arcade games
with good success
there were even castle only fighting
games like
bubsy
balls 3d
okay maybe that one wasn't so good wait
hold on i just noticed this the clown's
name is boomer how did this game predict
2021 internet culture i take back
everything 10 out of 10. there were of
course new genres innovative ideas and
games that felt like true risks that
came during the super nintendo era i'm
talking games like actraiser which was a
totally unique god simulator which
combines city building with action
platform game design or harvest moon the
first farming simulator game and one
that showed how strangely fun and
addictive simple chores could be take
over battle a completely unique tactical
rpg that deserved far more attention
than it got
all of the games hit that perfect point
of still looking and sounding good today
thanks to good pixel graphics and art
design it was a magical era that took
many of the lessons learned on the nes
and applied them to a new generation and
while i love indie games today there's
something special about aaa game studios
investing all their money and talent on
these kinds of games and while many of
these games aren't that complex i think
that's part of what makes them still
hold up today at the end of the day a
good game doesn't always need a ton of
bells and whistles by taking a simple
mechanic say jumping on platforms while
avoiding enemies and mastering this
design you have yourself a timeless game
and that's how i think of the super
nintendo it's absolutely timeless and 30
years later i love the system just as
much today as i did when i first played
it as a child while the super nintendo
struggled at first in the united states
thanks to high competition from the sega
genesis eventually it pulled away around
49.1 million snes consoles sold
worldwide and in the us by the end of
its life cycle the snes had narrowly
beaten out the sega genesis and sales by
2 million systems
today the super nintendo lives on thanks
to his legacy gamers can pick up
collections of these games play many on
the switch with the nintendo switch
online membership or even enjoy modern
games that knowingly or unwittingly have
taken inspiration from some of super
nintendo's finest
thank you super nintendo for a lifetime
of memories
[Applause]
[Music]
you